je parle d'un concept un peu nouveau sur
la manière dont la science se
rapprochent maintenant de la
spiritualité la science aujourd'hui avec
l'aider à traverser dernières
découvertes tant à prouver que
maintenant on arrive dans quelque chose
de beaucoup plus spirituelle et qui va
falloir le prendre en compte et se livre
à travers toute cette richesse
d'expériences de docteur montre à quel
point maintenant on est dans une forme
de révolution qui amène nos médecins nos
scientifiques à se rapprocher maintenant
de tout l'aspect spirituel qu'il y a
dans le monde
à ma grande surprise j'ai écrit ce livre
qui est paru en octobre et j'ai fait
déjà six conférences qui ont fait salle
pleine
on a même dû refuser du monde donc je
pense que vraiment les gens soient
intéressés intéressés par ce phénomène
de deux de ralliement entre la science
et la spiritualité et surtout je crois
que les gens attendent maintenant
vraiment quelque chose qui change
quelque chose qui qui évolue qu'on les
prenne en compte
et aujourd'hui ce livre apporte
justement les clés de ce changement qui
passe par soi même grâce aux vibrations
quantique mais aussi grâce aux dernières
découvertes sur la mémoire et la
conscience de l'eau c'est cette prise en
compte
c'est aussi être positif avec soi même
et c'est aussi être vibrations positif
entre soi et le monde
alors vous parlez de plusieurs jeux
dans ce livre qui ont leur importance
vous parlez de la puissance de l'eau
vous parlez de l'infiniment petit alors
je parle effectivement de la physique
quantique donc la science de
l'infiniment petit qui nous prouve
aujourd'hui que tout ce que l'on voit
maintenant n'est pas réel en physique
quantique prouvé par la science on se
rend compte que tout ce que l'on voit
aujourd'hui n'est pas réel et donc
j'explique tout ça je parle de la
conscience et de la mémoire de l'eau car
il ya eu des découvertes par le docteur
montagnier prix nobel et qui a découvert
le sida donc très respecté qui lui a
découvert que l'eau a une mémoire
vous savez on est constituée de 70 % de
l'eau existent partout 70% d'eau dans la
planète
donc si on associe sa à la physique
quantique est la résonance vibratoire
clairement si l'eau a une conscience et
une mémoire on peut réellement se poser
la question de la manière dont on peut
vibrer notre propre conscience et notre
propre mémoire à l'extérieur dans notre
environnement